et retour en france direction
l'assemblée nationale ou non de
retrouver notre reporter nadège
abderrazak nadège les débats concernant
le projet de loi via commence à 15h
c'est un texte d'importance et le
premier sans lien avec le kobe 19 qui
est examiné par le parlement
oui c'est ça ce fut la dernière ligne
droite pour la loi a via la proposition
de loi qui vise à lutter contre les
contenus haineux sur internet et porté
par la députée de la majorité
laetitia avia doigts et bien être
étudiée pour une ultime lecture
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale en
vue d'une éventuelle adoption définitive
une loi qui selon ses détracteurs
mettent à mal la liberté d'expression
qu'est ce que cette loi a via un
précisément cette loi doit instaurer
l'obligation pour les plateformes et les
contenus de recherche est bien de
retirer sous 24 heures tout contenu
manifestement et ne sue et bien peine
d'être condamné à des amendes qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à 1 million 250
mille euros au nom de la liberté
d'expression le sénat dominé par
l'opposition de droite s'est opposé à
cette mesure phare mais ce sont les
députés de l'assemblée nationale qui
auront le dernier mot aujourd'hui cette
dernière lecture de la proposition de
loi a via intervient dans un contexte un
peu particulier puisque la députée a
l'air om de paris en charge de cette
proposition de loi est accusé par
d'anciens collaborateurs de proférer
régulièrement à des propos racistes et
sexistes et homophobes dans une enquête
publiée par mediapart
hier ils l'accusent aussi de méthodes de
travail humiliantes et harassante la
députée a annoncé son intention de
porter plainte
tout en expliquant que ses propos aient
bien avait été à des formes et des
accusations dont se serait bien passée
celle qui a mis est bien en place cette
proposition de loi contre la haine en
ligne heures merci beaucoup à l'aja
direct depuis l'assemblée nationale